I think you'll like this Without Really
Trying Republican senator and failed
presidential candidate Ted Cruz said
something kind of profound the other day
and I mean the truth is when trying Ted
Cruz never says anything that's profound
but I guess what I mean is he
accidentally stumbled across a profound
way to sum up the American gun problem
in one sentence I'm gonna play a little
more than just the one sentence for you
for context but here's what Ted Cruz had
to say you know it is an unfortunate
thing that the immediate place the media
goes after any tragedy after any murder
is politicizing it we don't need
politics right now you know I would note
in New York we saw a terror attack just
this week with a truck evil is evil is
evil and we'll use the weaponry that is
available evil is evil is evil and we'll
use the weaponry that is available Ted
Cruz is exactly right terrorists will
use whatever is available to them to
commit acts of terror to kill as many
people as possible but if less deadly
things are available they will use those
and end up killing fewer people if fully
automatic weapons are readily available
evil will use them and kill tons of
people
if the fully automatic weapons are
tougher to obtain then they might use
semi-automatic weapons and end up
killing fewer people if those become
harder to find they'll use handguns and
kill even fewer people Ted Cruz is
exactly right he's making an argument
for us to reduce the availability of
really deadly weapons so that so-called
evil people haven't more difficult time
accessing them
that's what gun safety advocates are
saying there are people in the world who
will try to hurt others and they will
use whatever is available to do it so
why wouldn't we work to make killing
machines less readily available if only
a baseball bat were available evil would
use it and end up killing way fewer
people if you chart the rate of gun
violence to the rate of gun ownership
around the world you'll see that the
united states has way more guns per
than most countries and way more gun
deaths per person than most countries
and part of it is availability the
Harvard School of Public Health's injury
control research center has consistently
found that when you control and adjust
for variables like socioeconomic factors
crime place other non gun crime places
with more guns have more gun deaths so
Ted Cruz sort of I guess maybe
accidentally wandered aimlessly into a
profound and accurate statement about
guns one that gun safety advocates
completely agree with him on but yet Ted
Cruz is one of the more guns in more
places with fewer restrictions and
regulations types of guys Ted Cruz and
people like him end up with ideas like
if you ban guns people will make
fertilizer bombs and kill just as many
people really every person who could use
a fully automatic weapon to kill dozens
of people is going through in the
absence of the availability of the fully
automatic weapons learn how to make a
fertilizer bomb and get the ingredients
make it and set it off no some of them
won't these same people end up with
talking points like hey cars kill people
too like the truck in New York which Ted
Cruz mentioned but no one wants to ban
them yet we require training and
licensing and insurance for driving cars
and people like Ted Cruz don't want
those same things for owning and having
guns and of course cars also do have
another purpose right it's not that the
only thing you can do with cars is kill
people you can also use cars for
transportation you can use cars for
building businesses the car is one that
really gets to me because the reasoning
is so bizarre right cars have legitimate
uses that far outweigh the uses for
terrorism and for running into people
all that other stuff guns are designed
for killing people even knives right
knives have endless other purposes than
violence cooking crafts woodworking
whatever whatever it is that you do with
knives
so these arguments are so specious that
they barely even require refutation but
we still hear it from a senator of the
United States
these examples are distractions but Ted
Cruz's statement actually tells me that
deep down he gets it right evil is evil
is evil and will use whatever is
available to it that's what terrorists
will use whatever is available so then
let's make some of these killing tools
less available sort of obvious in a way
isn't it the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad